Surreal more than anything else.
Feeling like I was in a dream I mean these
Movies are so big, the sets are so big
The costumes are incredible.
Feels like you're inside a TV screen and then
There's the added part where you can't talk about it
So the end of your day, it's not
like you can call your mom and be like
"You'll never believe what I did
today."
So you just kind of delete it
So it feels like you're walking into a dream really.
I guess pretty good.
I just saw it the other day and
yeah, there's a lot of people going to dust
That's pretty sad.
Because before you didn't have me.
Yeah, you didn't.
That's right so I guess it's pretty good.
It's challenging because there are so
many characters but you know something
that we learned on Captain America: Civil
War, Joe and I
That movie was the first movie that we did
That had a really large number of characters in it
And what we realized as we were crafting
that movie was that it doesn't
Necessarily matter how much screen time that character has.
It's just what you do with it.
You know there's characters in
Civil War for instance
Like Spider-Man or Ant-Man, they didn't have a lot of screen time in that movie
But they were able to make a big impact and I think audiences were really able to
Enjoy and get a lot out of their time on
screen.
So that's really how we try to balance and shape the movie
It's like we make sure that all the time that each character has
Is very meaningful, and
memorable, and exciting.
I mean I... No.
Because this is it, everything
we've got is in this.
There will probably be
you know, a handful of deleted scenes on
the DVD but it's not many
I mean we really
We put everything, all the stories in there
We are done for now. We don't have any.
I mean one of the creative upsides I think
In terms of how we approach this movie
Is we weren't thinking about the future.
There's no future for us right now in the MCU
And this story was since intended to be a conclusion
As opposed to a setup to something coming in the future
But we love Marvel
We love these stories
We love these characters
We've had the greatest run for the past seven years making these four movies
So with the right material, Joe and I
would certainly do another Marvel movie.
I'm giving that one at 10.
Have you worn that one?
I love that you got a nice little mini dress with a plunging neckline
And a belt
And a boot
Chic!
It's pretty awesome. That's my favourite one.
10.
So this is actually Hawkeye in the 1990s.
Nice headpiece
I'm going to go with 8 for that one.
Oh man I mean all... everytime you hang out with that guy
That guy... It's not even so much that I had like to sit down with him
But it's more every time I was just
thinking about him actually before you sat down
Said, "Wow I miss him."
And he's got such a
Like a cheeky smile on his face always
A very, very smart guy but he's got a
youthful spirit until his last moments
you know.
He's always... He has a fire in his heart, and he's a cowboy
It's in his body
This fortitude and strength.
And he always had a smile on his face
And his, you know, lightness to him that was infectious
That was every experience I've had with him
Always just such a wonderful, giving, thoughtful guy.
I just had one experience but I'm so
grateful to have had that one.
It's one of the many things that I think about
About this entrance into this Marvel Universe
That I had the opportunity to
have a cameo time with him
Yeah I mean, I just think it's with his
energy on set.
When everyone would hear his voice
And it'll just like turn everyone
into kids again I think
You know there's a lot of movie stars that work on these movies but you know there was
More energy and excitement when Stan was on set than anybody.
I remember our first cameo with Stan was on Winter Soldier
And I remember him coming to set that day
It was the first time we met him
and just the
Just having that first impression of him was so amazing.
The way he came onto set
He just lit up the room
And the energy that he brought was amazing for his age.
And I think I was so impressed with his level of enthusiasm
That he still was so
Passionate and excited to be telling these stories.
That really struck me and stuck with me.